[Musica]
irritato resti io sono li caricano sono
supercontento azione un centesimo
cioccolato vita ne so è saltato perché
sapete che un mangiare un colore allora
il nuovo tablet dolci normali per soci
giganti di cioccolato nel gigante
supermercato abbiamo visto che hanno
fatto della terza vincita anche di
alcuni dolci ho pensato che non facciamo
una challenge
se io delle facciate e ogni round
metteremo il dolce normale e girante in
una di queste clause poi uno a testa
potremo decidere se è costretto a me
decidere se tenerlo o scambiarla poi ma
non era maggior scarto ma una volta che
abbiamo deciso possiamo tirar su da
cross vedere cosa ci è capitato e
mangiarlo capitale per forza mangiavano
tutto però perché come di capistrano di
notificanti rimonterà vittoria di mario
ti garantisco che tutto non lo mangio
ham perchè comunque lascerò da parte la
carta tutto il resto che c'è una buona
cosa
e vitale spera che dica se vuole
insegnante così può mangiare perché il
cioccolato e io spero che vi capiti un
collegio grandi così non li mangia tutti
vitale bel laiche se volete vedere altre
challenge mogherini vorrei fare questa
challenge perché ho scoperto che ci sono
altri in versione in gigante quindi se
nostro video se 10 mila ex andremo a
rifarlo nuovamente secondo episodio ha
dovuto subire da vedere il canale di
vitale 3 chiamami il canale digitale
quindi è facile da ricordare perché
abbiamo fatto sapere video su distinse
abbiamo fatto il matrimonio poi andato a
finire mai citato dal sun che titola
oggi ha premeditato aned e parodie
concordi in questo caso il cioccolato
perché vivere
mettetevi comodi video tutto schermo ed
allora è agitatissimo calmati calmati
mi piace la mia ho scambiato l'hanno
scambiato lo scriviamo un cambiamento
allora il primo abbiamo per il gigante è
un formaggio dell'inter normale se dal
dettaglio te ne stai mangiando uno
normale no mentono processo perché cerco
the bay non ferrero rocher volasse
ferrero rocher all'interno e ferrero
rocher mamma che vi per le loro tre
figli all'interno vediamo fare la mamma
dei terreni lo sai questa vitale
golosissimo fate sistemare i commenti
neanche voi siete così mi scuserò e la
fin de uguale
ecco qua partiamo canino il fiocchetto
sopra sono pure stati stabiliti
all'interno
vorrei saggiare quello che saluta no
stanza due università ma c'è un letto di
plastica dentro uno scherziamo
cioccolato e ancorarlo dove sta come
plastica poi quasi una linguetta per
aprirlo vediamo scelta
cosa c'è e cosa che hanno un pallettone
norma che pilota che ci sia niente
dentro è sciolto ci sono un modo per
scoprirlo al 9 che disastri vita ai
casalesi comunque dentro 0 2
se si è un po diverso dei parolo share
del nocciolino sembrano tipo caramellato
buona tempra netta c'è lo strato di
cioccolato e noccioline dentro
richiudiamo e nascondiamo perché siamo
stiamo cosa farà acquistarlo
e non solo di fare non l'ho mai da tutto
di nice côte ma voglio capito perché non
posso fare lo stesso con vitale perché
sanno già tutto facendo molto bene
vista così tanta perché allora questa
volta che lo desiderino
comunque la moto non riesco a vedere io
spero che non capiti attaccano grande
cosa
[Musica]
e lo tengo ok 32
e così capita anche piccolo e guarda non
è per dirti è giusto ma guarda scorso è
scaduto da mangiare leggo mi guarda mi
sacrifico realta che vuoi mangiare così
non è vero che è scaduto quando accade
2019 beh mi disse certo perché non mi
guarda mi voglio che il mio talento no è
rischioso per tempo che non fai se ti
senti male non puoi fare video almeno
[Musica]
svaso calmano cosa c'è scritto l'amore
che non si rinnova ogni giorno diventa
un'abitudine
devo abituarmi a mangiare cioccolato
nella lora apriamo questo cioè fatto
benissimo che carino un tubo la forma e
la stessa anche la carta il canino
vediamo un po come un sasso destro di
aprirlo perché troppo carino a me mossa
tutto cio colato ma non il cioccolato
borghetto e plastica blu vediamo che
sono stato fortunato ion mangiare tutto
[Applauso]
san rocco però bello bello bacione e
dentro ci sono due i due bazzini un
baciare e un bacino 4 nei due bacini
passaggio vicino ma vediamo come il
cioccolato di questo bacione da lei
chiamato non solo guardando fondente
buono non devo dire e molto fondente
foto forte dai presenti sono io trovo
tutto questo non se la passano già
prodotto mi hai già detto uno fa un
buono super fondente buoni
[Musica]
biglietti non altro bacio è stato bene
visto che sono mai stati non lo abbiamo
visto dall'interno
[Musica]
no c'è scritto qualcosa basta più questa
salvarla
allora perche il prossimo c'è un piccolo
problema di spazio non so se si nota la
differenza
comunque diciamo che si capisce dove è
quello più grande evento non è quello
che picco io sono indeciso trattenerlo e
cambiarlo velata 20 ma francamente
perché l'aic ha perso a verso di
scambiarlo non ne sono sicuro ma non
puoi decidere su questa volta perché
ovvio dove troveranno d'aiuto per me
questo voto che ci dobbiamo fare carta
forbice stato tre volte tre volte altre
volte invece no carta forbice sasso 10
carta
ho vinto uno a uno attenzione che per la
battaglia dipinti ma allora sono
indeciso e ripeto sono indeciso non so
se tenete questo serve una robusto qui
più evidentemente sono dieci sono molto
indeciso la perché questo qui essendo
grande penso ci sia quello grandi cui
sapevo né inganni prendo questo è bello
scambio
[Musica]
non so se ho fatto bene ma la cosa che è
brutto non dura ma noto il dubbio che
forse mi sono sbagliato che qua sotto
c'è quello grande però vediamo subito 23
il suo valore è truccato dalla mia testa
ma niente plastica dentro o no ai se
solo fosse tutto cioccolato e cioccolato
prostrato rinchiuso nella plastica
mettere veramente il più grande di tutti
guardate la differenza è debole ed invio
e via verdi dai prima primi a sì io devo
capire come piatto
ecco qua tra l'altro chi non sono voluta
come vitale infatti non ce la faccio più
ho già mancato troppo cioccolate domando
spesso non mangia tanto cioccolato e
lasciatelo per me come le piante possono
accettare in grassi era tutto lo sport è
bello troppo curioso di vederlo
io troppo curioso di poggiardo è tutto
bloccato
gli otto strati di scotch di voi spero
di non tagliare di numerosi paesi di
tutta la carta tutto treno
ma le botticelle come la poké ball hoc e
cioccolato
io sono così cioccolato come quello
subito subito basta uno del mondo lego
entrati ovuli dormienti sequestrati
tutti che di questo mi sa che cosa
sbagliata sebbene buon chiudiamo detto
tutto la tela sotto la donna della mia
vita è bello quando tutti gli altri
la società ringrazia sottana 1 che
andiamo cioccolato le stelle e in questo
sono di cioccolato cioccolato svago
perché i nuvoletta il cioccolato stato
in cioccolata la fragola mio fa gola a
tutti gli spettatori sta avvenendo di
diabete e c'è pure a me proprio che ci
prova allora tutti contento non ad 1
milione mangia tutto quel cioccolato non
è detto perché ne abbiamo giorno di più
allora qual è piaciuto di più e tra
questi cioccolato questi l'inps i baci o
il ferro è piaciuto il budget serve loro
charme ma non perché è giusto perché
piaciuto mangiati quello fatto meglio
forse migliaia di più se allora fateci
sapere nei commenti testa dal momento
che viaggi il time stamp a me quando ho
distrutto il paese o scrivete nei
commenti solo ospitale non una vita ma
ritornano in italia ma allora perché
appena finirà questo video io dovrò
lottare lottare cominciamo a fare in
modo che non li mangi tutti basta come
stai mettendo in tasca
non ci credo di stare con me mi manca
informazione che vasche piene non sono
affatto ad altri sono spaventata la
donna ragazzi ora di montale perché devo
nascondere tutto
come vedete d'italia sta comportando
bene tra l'altro ultime sintassi
fiorenti a contarsi
dopo prova contabili vieni ragazzo mi
raccomando lasciate un bel like su
questo video se volete vederne altri
consumatori racconti scrivete un
commento alitalia mentre cioccolato e
rovigo al 4 castellino e poi cliccare
per vedere le nostre altre challenge
teatri video divertenti questa era solo
una lastra di cliccare su quella che
preferite
buongiorno